if you love diversity so much that in
the name of diversity you'll bow down to
an ideology that demands complete
uniformity if you worship tolerance so
devoutly that you'll gladly sacrifice
your sons and daughters on the altar of
Tolerance like the pagans of old used to
sacrifice their sons and daughters if
you're so ashamed of your country's
history of colonialism that you
desperately want to be colonized because
you think think this will somehow atone
for the past have I got some awesome
news for you from Reuters Muhammad was
most popular boy's baby name in England
and Wales in
2023 well it's about time Fox News
Muhammad becomes most popular baby name
in England report as of 2023 Muhammad
was also the fourth most popular baby
boy name in Europe only fourth in Europe
come on Europeans you're falling behind
Great Britain what are you bunch of
islamophobes show the world how tolerant
you
are the telegraph Muhammad is most
popular baby name for boys for first
time for the first time and for many
many years to come once you go Muhammad
you don't go back the BBC Muhammad
overtakes Noah as most popular boy's
name
Noah I guess you guys were getting ready
for a flood smart because the flood has
arrived London Muhammad was the most
popular name given to baby boys in
England and Wales in 2023 outing Noah to
take the top spot official figures
showed on Thursday Muhammad had been
among the 10 most popular names since
2016 and had been in second place in
2022 according to the annual list
produced by the office for National
statistics Oliver replaced George as the
third most
popular
Oliver you're soon to be conquerors are
naming their babies after a man who
ordered his followers to humiliate and
degrade you and you're naming your
babies after an orphan in a Charles
Dickens
novel but don't worry because I'm about
to explain why it's actually good that
the people of Great Britain are
surrendering it's going to be good for
the rest of the world of course some
people aren't as thrilled as you or I
about the rapidly growing percentage of
muhammads in that masochistic
subjugation fetish dungeon British
people used to call home why is that
why wouldn't everyone want millions and
millions of baby muhammads growing up in
Great Britain and learning to imitate
the man they were named
after perhaps these British islamophobes
are alarmed because they've read a few
Quran verses perhaps they've read Surah
98:6 verily those who disbelieve in the
religion of Islam the Quran and Prophet
Muhammad from among the people of the
scripture Jews and Christian chrans and
Al musun musun are people who associate
partners with Allah will abide in the
fire of hell they are the worst of
creatures according to the Quran Jews
Christians and other non-muslims are the
worst of creatures we're lower than pigs
and we should be treated as such then
there's Sur 5 verse 51 oh you who
believe do not take the Jews and the
Christians for friends
they are friends of each other and
whoever amongst you takes them for a
friend then surely he is one of them
surely Allah does not guide the unjust
people no friendship with Jews or
Christians what should they do with Jews
and Christians Surah 9 verse 29 fight
those who do not believe in Allah nor in
the latter day nor do they prohibit what
Allah and his Apostle have prohibited
nor follow the religion of Truth out of
those who have been given the book Jews
and Christians until they pay the tax in
acknowledgment of superiority and they
are in a state of
subjection maybe the British
islamophobes are concerned that so many
babies are being named in honor of the
man who brought these powerful
Revelations from his Arabian Desert
Genie or they may be afraid because so
many babies are being named after a man
who said in sah Muslim 33 I've been
commanded to fight against people till
they testify that there is no God but
Allah that Muhammad is the messenger of
Allah and they establish prayer and pay
zakat and if they do it their blood and
property are guaranteed protection on my
behalf except when justified by law and
their Affairs rest with Allah they may
have seen video clips of mothers in war
zone saying they want their children to
become
Martyrs where did these mothers get
their obsession with
martyrdom soari
2797 Muhammad the fake Prophet not the
cute little British babies said by him
in whose hands my life is I would love
to be martyred in Allah's cause and then
get resurrected and then get martyred
and then get resurrected again and then
get martyred and then get Resurrected Ed
again and then get
martyred always good to name a
generation of children after a Man Who
Loved martydom almost as much as he
loved his prepubescent child bride but
maybe these British islamophobes haven't
read anything in Islam's most trusted
sources maybe they simply watched some
Ali dawa videos on YouTube maybe they
saw Ali dawa explaining what he plans to
do to ex-muslims when Islam finally
takes over this is a part of our
religion there's a reason to it yeah
there's a reason why there's a capital
punishment because people like you
little weaklings who leave their
religion and cause uh corruption in the
land by spreading it the capital
punishment in Islamic law would be
applied to you we have no doubt and
we're proud of that or they could be a
bit creeped out because Ali dawa's wife
has to communicate using a whiteboard
she's not going to be in the video but
she's going to have her say um with this
white that I B to her okay there
something my wife wants to say or they
could have seen what Muhammad hijab said
about children in the Quran if you look
just at the Quran you will get the
indication that you can have sexual
intercourse of the 5-year-old Muhammad
hijab was also kind enough to share what
he thinks about non-muslim women who
criticize Islam he thinks they secretly
want to be taken captive and used by
their new new Masters hijab said I
believe certain anti-muslim women would
wish they lived in the medieval period a
period where if a war was won by the
opposing side it was conventional that
people could be taken as booty some
historical accounts actually say some
women would dress up for the
captor always a good idea to let a guy
like this named Muhammad to train the
Next Generation of
muhammads we could go on and on with
Quran passages and Hadith passages and
videos and tweets and protests and
grooming gangs who knows why British
islamophobes would be concerned about
Muhammad being the number one baby name
in the
UK maybe they've noticed how the British
government is sending British citizens
to prison for complaining about what's
happening maybe they're doing the mass
and thinking to themselves if our
leaders are already locking us up to
silence us what are they going to do
when the Muslim population doubles again
how bad are things going to get for our
children poor Noah and
Oliver I don't know what they're
thinking I'm not British but I do know
there's a bright side for 14 centuries
Europeans understood that whatever they
disagreed about what whatever they
fought about they could not under any
circumstances allow Islam to take over
in Europe they understood
that fast forward to the past few
decades and European leaders suddenly
decided that the greatest thing they
could possibly do was raise the white
flag of surrender and hand their
countries over to
Islam I don't want them to hand their
countries over to Islam as much as I
don't care for France let's say I don't
want to see France subjugated by jihadis
I wouldn't wish that on anyone no matter
how eminite their language sounds I
don't want to see Great Britain or
France or Germany fall to Islam the
leaders have made up their minds and I
always look for the bright side what's
the bright side here I'll tell
you I really like it when people prove
me right because that will ultimately
help other people will catch on and
everything I've been saying for the past
two decades about what would be
happening right now it's all happening
right down to the letter and this isn't
me bragging about how smart I am anyone
with the ability to read words off a
page could have read the same words that
the shakes and imams were reading and
told you exactly what would happen if
Great Britain and France and Germany
adopted this
a 5-year-old can understand this so why
is it so difficult for some people to
understand well as easy as it is to
understand what Islam calls for it's
also easy to manipulate millions of
gullible people so here we
are when Islam targets your country for
subjugation your country is going to
help the rest of the world no matter
what you do if you're smart and you
figure out how to avoid being subjugated
which is pretty easy to figure out the
rest of the world is going to watch and
learn they'll say ah so that's how it's
done if on the other hand you're
insanely stupid and you pave the way for
your own subjugation which is what
you're doing the rest of the world is
still going to watch and learn they'll
say oh my goodness these people backed
down like total cowards and submitted to
the ramblings of an illiterate 7th
Century Arabian Caravan robber how
pathetic it's called vicarious
learning I've been warning people about
Islam for two decades lots of people
just didn't want to listen Islam taking
over Western Nations ha
impossible but if these doubters finally
see it happen with their own eyes I
think they'll be ready to listen
so thank you British politicians I would
have preferred you took things in a
totally different
direction but since I can't stop you
from sacrificing your own country and
your own people to the most obvious
false prophet in
history all I can do is promise you that
your
sacrifice will not be in vain
[Music]